l'épisode de cette semaine et présenté
par l'électronique recycling association
qui est un organisme à but non lucratif
qui recycle des objets électroniques
usagés ou désuets pourquoi dans le fond
réutiliser des arts électroniques c'est
parce qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
les moyens de s'en procurer qui en ont
besoin surtout dans cette période ci de
reconfirmer si vous avez peur avant de
laisser aller vos objets électroniques
que vous donnez suivent mais le 1er à un
système de destruction physique des
données ou d'effacement des données dont
vous n'avez même pas besoin d'avoir peur
que des photos de votre chien ou de
votre choses commencent dans les mains
de quelqu'un d'autre
si vous avez des objets électroniques
désuets chez vous que vous voulez pas
acheter parce que vous trouvez que ce
serait du gaspillage qui en auraient qui
en auraient besoin
vous pouvez appeler au 1 8 7 7 9 3 9 2 7
8 3 ou aller au triple w point à point
ca pour planifier une cueillette en ce
moment c'est ultra important il ya
beaucoup de monde qui se retrouve encore
avec le code rouge qui se retrouve
encore à devoir travailler de la maison
ou à devoir être à l'école à la maison
en fait c'est pas tout le monde qui ont
les instruments nécessaires pour que ça
fonctionne bien
donc si vous pensiez à vous débarrasser
d'un objet de matériel électronique en
fuite
attelage penser aux électronique
recycling association et donnez au
suivant
donc bon podcast introduction du sf vous
écouter sans fil podcasts les podcasts
on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités d'attitude implante avec moi ps
quant à walter
la suite cette semaine au sans fil pour
me reçu n'at il a aussi connu sous le
nom de la grosse qui fait des vidéos qui
est view to buzz qui est instagram euse
sa crise qui est animatrice du podcast
black gold from laval qui est
enregistrée ici d'un podcast extrêmement
pertinents on a parlé de évidemment des
mouvements sociaux en lien que le
blacklight vendeurs on a parlé de son
expérience au québec à elle l'expérience
dans le paysage médiatique québécois qui
on va se le dire plutôt blanc on a aussi
parlé de only fun nadal est un onni fin
on only fans solide pardon whisky à
monétiser son contenu en fait si on en a
parlé longuement ça fait du bien ce
genre de conversation de son iphone vont
me parler un petit peu des jeux dans le
passé mais là on avait vraiment un autre
tout autre perspective donc super belle
conversation et nayla on espère que vous
allez l'aimer autant que nous donc suivi
nous abonner ou changer les idées
commentaires abonnés nous abonnez vous
sur notre pays triomphe est toujours
encore moins de filtres condé bruits
font parle de plus en profondeur des
podcasts convient d'avoir les
seigneuries thing fait tout ce que ph
vous disent pas d'habitude le pire n'a
certes pas facile
bonne écoute
[Musique]
bal à la table est tournée pour toi
habituellement si ton podcast que toi tu
animes ici comme adam seule expérience
d'animer un podcast est bizarre ça parce
que j'ai donc parlé longtemps mais
pourrait j'aime ça et musique au top de
faire ça avec ça tout bien comme ça sa
sortie dans les prochaines semaines on
sait pas encore je consomme dans les
messages christelle et possiblement
moment ça va sortir avec aussi parce que
cette habitude sur ma chaîne tout seul
dans ma chambre
alors maintenant je pu converser avoir
une discussion n'est autre que dans le
vide parce que l'agir sa part est elle
aussi mais bon des fois c'est le
fantasque et très bon ton de la
conversation d'avoir un feedback c'est
quoi pourquoi est ce que votre mission
n'en voit pas tout en paca s'appelle
blagueur sur la piste equal c'est quoi
l'idée il a beaucoup tout la face à elle
à fond j'ai vraiment envie d'avoir une
plateforme où est ce que on peut éviter
toute sorte de gens sans limite et parce
que souvent c'est ça c'est que tout est
mais je dors dans la vie en général tout
est vraiment heureux centre est et tout
fait là je me suis dit bon mais regarde
si je mange avec des gens qui tournent
en fait tout le monde
alain stand d'inviter des gens qui leur
ressemblent cette île c'est moi déjà si
j'avais dû des anguilles me ressemble je
vais faire la chose que tout le monde
sauf que comme il n'a pas beaucoup comme
moi c'est l'info de la fête aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs bh oui exactement on ne s'est
pas inquiété sur sa défense 4 10 euros
centre et s'est centrée sur la guest
l'occident européen
ouais puis tu trouves que j'imagine que
je sais que tu vas donner
j'aimerais qu'on approfondisse parce que
chez que c'est quelque chose qui tient
encore comment la tribune québécoise est
très blanche très très monochrome en
fait puis d'avoir un podcast comme ça de
capter de de prendre cette parole là
j'imagine ça va un petit peu aussi dans
l'objectif de lutter contre ce oui
vraiment oui parce que dans les
commentaires tu viens nouvellement c'est
mon endroit préféré moment je partage
souvent des bons endroits préférés ou
mon enfant sur six est petit dans tous
les sens on a répondu sont plus faciles
ensuite tant que la mère partie après
c'est vrai que je réponds lassons pas
chier plairont sûrement profite d'être
comme à mellac façon à la menthe et gros
de l'accès des vidéos therion c'est que
les autres ils se trouvent dans mes
champs harry pause mais a fait comment
ils partagent le métro annezin regarde
la commande à l'affichage merci pour la
pub sont fâchés les cobras une pub choc
ils viennent chaton qui viennent sur ta
page puis 10 on se bat et grosse fuite
fait des vidéos ci littéralement le nom
d'achat
à bientôt aller directement sur parce
que d'habitude ils voient mon mur puis
viennent essayer de m'insulter sur tva
nouvelles directement pour que c'est
pareil pour ces gens votent comme ouais
c'est vrai elle est grosse comme si elle
gosat empêche d'avoir des dix
d'arguments mettons ces aides
quel genre d'article genre de
commentaires aussi de répondre tout ce
qui est raciste ou même largement accès
à plus largement que ça vraiment
n'importe quoi ce que tu trouves qui a
pas de bassin plat japon place à qui je
dois passer ses journées à faire non pas
tant et qui m'a tant que j'y vais tu me
donnes ou qui seraient pas tout le monde
qui pendant 15 minutes
ensuite j'ai envie de notification c'est
comme alan mais oui c'est vrai il ya des
réseaux pvr nouvelle je me dis que les
réponses le gage de samatan sedan il y a
deux ans où il ya trois ans j'essaie de
situation fait que dès qu'ils écrivaient
je répondais des claviers comme ça c'est
la meilleure façon de gamme et soir
était la maîtresse ainsi pas d'amis fait
que j'ai passé la soirée
pourquoi je pense à mes tours et âme a
réussi à faire changer d'idée quelqu'un
sur les réseaux sociaux comme ça oui
ah ouais oui toi si ça marchait pas je
considérais pas tout le monde mais c'est
pas les personnes qu'on pense qui change
l'enfance ou exemple et moi je la
jeunesse kanake dooms internet
ouais ça lui soit way peut-être il dit
s'attendre à un bon on sait pas parler
ça juste lu les commentaires
alors si tu viens privé écoute mais là
j'ai vu de la conversation j'ai que si
je pense pas et c'est toi qui change qui
reste la même personne mais à la base
c'est parce que parce que dans une fois
qu'il va te répondre plusieurs fois tu
le feras pas changé c'est fini il est
des fois qu'il y aura des fois que je me
serais la qpc comme un mois plus tard un
an plus tard tu étais les gens
reviennent sont comme elle
en 2008 je te croyais pas mais non mais
non se comprend justement à l'eau dit
venez d'un clan jamais trop tard et
jamais trop tard mais en plus je me dis
parce que tout le monde trouve que la
manière est pas bonne parce que je
trouve directes 6 h comme c'est correct
mais en même temps où les gens qui
reviennent plus tard c'est parce que
j'étais vraiment je dirais qu'au début
que quand d'autres personnes viennent
les flatter dans le dos qui comprennent
autre chose c'est clairement un compte
si tout le monde fera tout le monde à
dos sa part de fossiles s'apprennent
pleurer la pluralité de metalor sur
l'autre jour de rose aimée autant
démarrage c'est qui qui ont par le
féminisme et c'est la même chose qui
disait à diana qui vont l approche
al'approche pisser avec la diversité des
approches qu'on veut c'est à rejoindre
le plus de gens parce que le arnaud
arnaud sol il sait lui ai quitté les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'ils étaient
capables ok mais je lui ça l'était quand
les gens parce que lui dans le fond il a
fait des vidéos est ce qui est un peu
des gens qui critiquent la masse qui
écrira t pie ix au sud il messages
d'insultés ni fini ni reçu des menaces
de mort juste pour porter main waouh
ok ça surprend vraiment mais non mais je
pensais son vidéo était quand même été
parce que la vidéo qui est fait sur ce
il est devenu viral tellement de lampard
milliers fait que c'est ça s'est rendu à
du monde qu'il connaît
2 c'est un peu le gars qui te réponds
sur une caricature d'un autre qu'alex 70
parme en visite au téléphone dans les
croyances vraiment profonde
cette attaque qui a l'identité même de
la personne avec des gens qui sont super
attaqué par sa faiblesse
il recevait des menaces de mort insultes
tout ce que tu veux puisqu'il apport des
métaux réjean lui écrivait pour
l'insulter il répondait salut région
comment ça va il dit des fois la moitié
du temps il continue d'insulter puis
d'autres fois c'est embêtant si cette
fois ça finissait pas en tout cas je
t'aime impôts mais mon ego ton show
prochaine fois tu vends mes billets
[Musique]
c'est vrai que les gens sont rapides à
s'insulter mais c'est rare qu'on dise
que pauvre et les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux si ce camp mais voilà
dix ans que radicaliser comme com
tu es rôle
un lieu où en général les idées sont
rade qu'elle échoue mais c'est que tu as
l'opportunité de dire ce que je pense
plutôt fils du reste ouais c'est déjà la
télé quand même un peu essayé que la
foule soit un peu à quoi bon si tu sors
mon profil moi c'est ce que je vous ai
mes règles fait que j'ai pas besoin de
penser a besoin plein de gens qui
considèrent pas besoin de penser là mais
c'est pourquoi au fond ces quelques ça
pourrait me laisses tes x fait que l'ex
enfant jusqu'à moi je pense pas à moi je
dis ça maintenant ouais mais je pense
que je dois parler c'est que je pense
que c'est difficile de d'exprimer toutes
les nuances d'une idole en mai ce sera
avec un court texte aussi teen mom
actuelle écrit cécile storti demande si
ben ça y est ça reste le kit handiski
méthodes d'une conversation mettons tu
vas parler quelqu'un a privé face à face
une forêt de temps avec une bière sans
alcool
pis la conversation va être beaucoup
plus justement numérique et lesquelles
ces personnes le voit paraître sur les
réseaux sociaux
très souvent c'est moi même de la
beaucoup trop de gens qui le mexique et
à qui je parle en privé plutôt parce que
disent les gens gagnent à insulter sur
le voile mais ceux qui viennent en privé
je parlais que pas en plus souvent je
leur dis si tu veux vraiment parler
vient de dire si tendresse sur le wan
moi ça me dérange pas moi je m'amuse to
move
moi je pourrais tu m'as fait que les
gens sont comme ok mais tu es tu as plus
de nuances que je pensais que comme aux
touristes comment tout va penser autre
chose je ne connais pas comme je sais
pas pourquoi tu as pensé que c'est comme
en suisse
la semaine commence avec moi parler aux
gens la gagne par le genre
c'est sûr que la polarisation comme ça
des opinions sur les réseaux sociaux est
liée grandement à la au cosec
l'algorithme pousse clairement des
droite ou gauche et bonoumin noir ou
blanc 6 août il vraiment ddd façon très
claire et très précises devant la vie ce
pic le reste n'est pas poussé là c'est
maintenant le stonewall ce soir ce sera
pas l'article écrit à 1500 mots qui vont
être vu le qui va être partagé ça va
être leur type 2 un silent hill puis
mais sinon ça va être le poste twitter
qui flashent qui va être partagé sera
tout est exposé aux gens qui pensent
comme toi puis justement le thé les gens
qui voient confrontés c'est tellement
potes dans leur quotidien dans leur vie
dans vos discussions avec une personne
comme toi mais ton article qui vient
d'un creusement d'un autre planète pour
les autres que j'étais au bout du mans
pour des combats du monde fait la
première fois qu'il conversation avec
quelqu'un qui est différent le tpiy
je pense que c'est ici on vit de plus en
plus dans notre réalité
mais ce que tu fais dans le fond pas
manquer chez politique il doit refaire
un petit peu en les piquant mais c'est
quand même c'est quand même mon moyen
pauvert deux réalités qui est en contact
c'était bien contacté le cd fois c'est
que même si j'admets j'attaquais chaud
pour leur répondre c'était bien nous
vers clamart ont subi au moins ça allait
[Rires]
mais mais c'est ça revenons à la
question que je posais initialement
c'est à dire quelqu'un parce que l'on
parle de tvh et tout quand même peut
quand même faire une campagne c'est un
pur legendre sur les chroniqueurs les
animateurs de tv offre de quebecor est
ce que tu penses qu'il ya une façon pour
la diversité d'entrer dans ces médias
lourds est ce que tu penses que c'est
c'est de trouver un média alternatif
comme justement une chaîne youtube
un podcast pour être capable de
traverser ces six décès la personne qui
gère pas je vais toucher la personne qui
gère avait envie de changer veut
l'entendre que leur change et puis même
je pense parce que j'ai tellement de
terrain est ce que tu penses que les
récents événements ont fait progresser
cette pensée l'annoncé dans les médias
traditionnels non avec le blacklight
madère puis toute l'espèce de lever
qu'on voit aujourd'hui ce que tu penses
que ça juste passé dans le vide
parce que là on est combien de mois
depuis la mort de tolstoï depuis les
manifs contre 3 4 mois maintenant
tandis qu'en 125 me fixer sur trois mois
mettant les trois mois plus tard à ce
que je pense que il ya des changements
clair qu'ils vont rester ou non non non
prisma live mais ils ont en tout cas je
vois pas encore parce que l'ancien
scrutés avant hier un toc et noir il ya
encore
c'est pas vu qu'il en est vraiment plus
de changements puis même mais maintenant
on compte 7 gagne la même entente
mettant je t'ai blanche si jamais je
t'ai blanche même pour les blancs c'est
pas de diversifier tout le monde a le
même âge que mon analyse externe et
hétéros tout le monde et si ce qu est ce
que tu fais
y'a comme prouvés un gay ou infamous
meco même pour les blancs se foule pas
de janvier avec imagine le reste comment
est ce pour ça que je passe au calme et
une envie de changer au moins y aurait
des changements ou moins à l'inter en
même temps je pense que je pense que
pour beaucoup de monde du moins il ya eu
un changement de mentalité sylvie avec
le chant mentalités se transforme un
changement concret dans l'organisation
des médias ou des gouvernements ou au
début ça prend plus de temps pour aider
j'ai failli renverser mon doigt mais
c'est ce type puis je prends l'exemple
chemins parallèles mais ton avec gabriel
nadeau-dubois le braquage plusieurs fois
pitt y mettons moi j ph ou si je pense à
l'époque et il y avait eu les cauris
rouge le tpiy le mouvement étudiant
petit mot j'avais lu bien impliqué là
dedans
pete est sur le coup c'était gros
tournant par les pythies on veut jamais
qu'un mouvement soit juste en traîne t
on dit si on veut pas s'asseoir parce
que ça soit fini tu veux pas les
manifestations ça devrait entamer une
personne qui porte encore aujourd'hui
guy pearce et c'est normal serait il ya
des moments aussi
c'est sur leur sa douche ou sur leur
manteau
métis qui disait c'est que les bienfaits
de ce mouvement alors les conséquences
positives du mouvement c'est plus tard
qu'on les voit c'est parce que oui oui
sur le couillon lyon annulé a osé
précarité puis ça a marché nature mais à
presque tous les gens qui ont été
éveillés par des politiques qui ont été
celles qui ont été prises cette cause
loeb qui ont voulu s'impliquer tout ça
c'est plus tard qu'on les voit
s'impliquer dans société peas et c'est
comme ça que j'ai l'impression que tu es
le mouvement la télé la trance tu veux
le tir les réseaux sociaux c'est plus je
sais que tu vois mais je vais quand même
l'impression que ce long terme on va
voir des effets qui vont se matérialiser
de sujets importants que oui mais dans
des médias alternatifs
ouais parce que c'est vraiment c'est
juste que ceux qui sont déjà en place
comme quand même beaucoup à gagner de
rester comme ça qu'on va parce qu'il ne
sait pas comme si mais sincèrement si
jamais ces maisons maj mais j'écoute la
télé la pub hommage problèmes identifiés
n'importe qui ok peut-être parce que je
suis né là dedans moi comme j'avais
donné comme exemple dans ramdam mois
chez marianne ok alors je m'identifie
très très très bien aux personnes qui
sont en or blanc jaune ou orange
ça fait que moi que tout le monde décide
de les boycotter en même temps tu vends
rien ils vont rien perdre vraiment à pas
nous mettre plus mais je comprends je
comprends ce que tu veux dire de mais en
même temps je trouve ça un peu d'écoles
sein qui avait pas des changements plus
rapides que moi c'est de dire de droite
et de concentrés de béton béton pour
reprendre l'exemple deux escouades 89 le
décor je trouve ça décolle sans que ça
soit pas un impact direct
cette année c'est correct mais la
prochaine fois à ses quatre lycées la
prochaine fois la maintenance des
boucles in my mind & co ah oui
investiture la prochaine fois maintenant
la meilleure nouvelle fois c'était la
meilleure prochaine fois qu on aurait pu
avoir
puis encore là les gens sont de la santé
vient nous vers l'avenir non mais la
prochaine fois
bon c'est quand non je comprends mais je
me dis
dire je sais que moi je parle la bouche
pleine le métier j'aurai des créneaux
mois
ben là au long le noter on est critiqué
c'est ça le vrai parce que de noter
critiquer c'est pas la première fois que
ça arrive sur une série télé 2 semaines
c'est la première fois que ça arrive
avec cette ampleur là parce que le monde
sont éveillés à cause des frais ou si
dans notre mémoire mais je me rappelle
très bien plusieurs autres fois où
est-ce que collectivement le monde
décrit ce qu'il n'y ait pas diversité à
l'elysée on se le disait souvent plutôt
d'une série pitt you rien mais tant que
le casting est fait n'est rien car
n'étant pas je ferai le genre ça fait
pas de sens lorsqu'on est en train de
faire leur métier
je ne peux pas de sens mendy cissé
carnet faux faux faux que tu prends des
décisions c'est radical qu'il retire r
je suis pas sur moi qui n'aurait pas
hésité à nous couper si jamais ça a été
le contraire qu'on avait mis une
haïtienne à la place de la halle à la
cnav que le québec s'est insurgé parce
que pourquoi c'est noir au lion pas sur
moi qu'ils auraient pas jusqu'à couper
la noix nous mettons à leur défense il
est quand même du lait personnage
principal de la série qu'ils sont noirs
oui mais c'est toi ça ça là s'il faut le
pire problème pour ça les gens peuvent
justement de dire mais c'est quand même
personne ne passe qu'à regarder son
passé benoît baby à la pause et j'en
prends parce que c'est pas comme c'était
une série originale dans les tâches
principales tu mets ton ok j'ai pas
quelle compagnie d' de médias décident
de faire une série originale écrite avec
deux personnages principal non ses
suppôts sol mais c'est comme tu prends
un concept qui existe déjà puni lui
blanchi les personnages c c'était ça qui
dérange et beewi les personnages prespa
vont rester noir mais ce procédé
original c'est la moindre des choses ne
changent pas
la couleur du chapeau show cuche je
trouve qu'il ya du monde qui devrait
être plus responsables en ce moment
surtout dans le climat actuel surtout
avec avec les veilles dames un con qu'on
a eus collectivement dernièrement j'ai
fait mais même est en toi
mettons que ça va être ta perception
tout en grandissant au québec c'est
comment tu te sens comment tu t'es senti
en écoutant des visions comment est ce
que tout ça est ce que ce soit et que
gt5 qui quittent inclus qui est exclue
mais ton généralement à baratte et les
noms mêmes et en vivent un grand timide
mais ton athlète je suis vraiment trop
large comme question la même et en gras
des eaux au québec
si tu te sens tu 706 inclus ou pas
vraiment de l'interpréter comme sur
cette question
c'est bizarre c'est que je ne me sens
pas nécessairement comme et exclus s'ils
ne me sens pas non plus incluses
comprend non sens où les gens mangent
pas je marche pas dans la rue en me
disant oh mon dieu ma voisine risque que
je donne qui dérogent pas si noir mais
j'ai pas l'impression que justement son
maître la télé on va juste nous mettre
parce qu'on vous la peine juste comme ça
pas juste pour dire j'ai mis un noir
vient nous mettre nous mêmes parce que
est bonne faut qu'on veut donner un rôle
pas juste pour remplir la case
shakespeare s'agit pas pour ça qu'on est
comme un client soit là mais c'est pas
non plus l'impression qu'ils étaient
selon leurs dépositions ya une
différence entre le québec et les états
unis comme comme on le vit présentement
dit si je pense que ce n'était pas
d'accord avec ce 4e différence oui
je suis une différence avec comment donc
comment ton voisin peut te regarder
c'est ça je pense que je pense que sa
personne doit vraiment rivage immigrants
je crois que les gens sont plus quant
aux états unis sacriste grands jeux des
îles vont enclencher dans la rue ici
c'est comme ils vont te parler dans ton
dos qui l'a traité de l oued mais comme
c'est pas dangereux pour ta vie c'est
justin dans ton dos parce que personne
ne veut avoir l'air méchant mais je
crois que c'est clairement un accent
coll mais si on veut tous avoir un
gentil fait c'est comme ça que les gens
en tout cas ici que de ce que je vois là
ils veulent pouvoir être raciste sans
qu'on leur dise aura six fait c'est
juste je pensais juste pour ça qu'après
une longue sont plus calmes parce que
ben devait pas avant l'heure mais show
soit racisme plus d'exhiber je comprends
métier on a parlé juste avant justement
type i télé terme raciste je pense pas
que beaucoup de gens qui le revendique
dans ce sens que je pense que beaucoup
de gens vont afficher fièrement t je
suis rincé apparaître des métaux et
demandes du québec et peut-être qu'ils
vont qui m'ont fait remarquer on veut
juste pas de criminels chez nous ah oui
parti met donc le racisme est tellement
souvent que les gens vont s'arrêter
qu'est ce que c'est bah oui c'est ce
méchant c'est parce que tu essaies comme
dom raciste et comme ce que l'éthique
est raciste et la paire personnes mais
en réalité je dire
crissement ce monde sont racistes à
différents degrés mais puisque je suis
comme être capable de le reconnaître
puis de travailler là dessus mais c'est
sa gare et puisque sommes d'accord déjà
en tout cas moi cause de gens qui sont
rasées c'est tout c'est pas parce que je
veux que ta vie s'arrête là je veux
juste que tu leur marque mais maintenant
qu'on le sait maintenant s'était dit bon
voilà c'est à dire que ce qui était
raciste
maintenant qu'on le sait comment on fait
pour que ça arrive plus tôt quand elle
n'a pas dit comment tu changerais si tu
sais pas te défaut pourquoi tu
changerais moi je comprends pas tu sais
c'est pour n'importe quoi si je te dis
maintenant que tu as atteint que ça dans
les dents
mais je te dis pas comment tu vas alors
déclaré c'est un grand nom des relations
coupe de faire quelque chose que tu sais
pas tu peux pas changer tant que
personne comme si ça faisait pas
longtemps à rentrer cantillon ils ont
évité plusieurs pénélope ô pénélope
n'est plus aux invités dont fabrice
ville puis les autres monsieur piste et
qui pour parler du livre white frigia
latine c'est quoi j'allais pas lu métier
je sais que je pense qu'une des prémices
des fondements sud se livrent le cd
d'affirmer qu' aimer tant en amérique
tous les blancs sont racistes le wat et
pilar autour de cette discussion là tout
le monde était d'accord sur ce fait de
jeu d'accord c'est j'ai dit jean phi phi
tu es là ça il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont réagi à ce te dis des chroniqueurs t
à la section des petits déj papa croit
qu'un tel istria la radio d'état
on dit que tous les québécois tous les
gens sont racistes ça pas de bon sens on
en a marre parce que je comprends tête
insurgés quand tu vois symboles comme si
c'était la pire chose sur terre happy
que ça voudrait dire que tous les
québécois sont mortes et risques et
qu'est-ce qui est personnes presque
personne ne se met ouvertement mais
quand donc ces petites mains par exemple
thomas caradec et oui mais comme dans la
même lignée que comme tout le monde a
des préjugés
ouais comme ceux sous tout le monde si
moi je me réveille je dis dans un micro
être moins à des préjugés par les vaches
et autres sa vraie mais se dit tous les
blancs des préjugés oh mon dieu c'est
nous attache coop mais quand j'ai dit
tout le monde c'est corey may des plans
sont du monde donc le blue collar exact
pitt et puis là encore le thé à être
raciste ou thé à certains certaines des
grilles qui avons des préjugés c'est en
fait ça va du préjudice de plus
définition du racisme mais donc tu sais
tu devrais les blancs tous les blancs
les préjugés les gens seraient comme on
peut choquer mais surtout les l'accord
mais si tous les bas-fonds racistes sont
très choqués mais c'est vraiment parce
que les gens n'ont plus peur du mot
qu'est ce que ces puits en pis j'essaie
de au travers la plate forme qu'à
travers tout ce que je fais aussi
j'essaye de parler du fait que le
racisme c'est pas juste toi envers moi
que c'est vraiment tout le système dans
lequel on vit pis comme tu as été à
l'école qui t'a appris de source aux
autochtones qui sont fausses pis d'état
des préjugés par rapport à 1 mais c'est
pas parce que tu as fait exprès c'est à
l'école qu'on l'a appris à prendre soin
on pense pas que tu as fait exprès c'est
juste que ça reste près jura c'est ce
que t'as vu c'est pas ta faute si
jusqu'à ce matin quand ledit faudra
qu'il ait changé parce que tant qu'on ne
fera pas tâche changera pas c'est pas
ccp récemment un choix conscient de ce
problème
un petit bon je joue l'étreint si c'est
ça sauf que quand l'information est là
par exemple que tu veux pas la voir
souvent jamais vraiment fâché contre les
gens pour ce qu'ils font maintenant mais
plus comment ils réagissent après
comment par exemple tu me dis quelque
chose aujourd'hui
puis jusqu'au améthyste ap négrophobe
hausse et un pub sexiste un peu grosse
frappe n'importe quoi si ta réponse
c'est comme au bon gars je savais pas je
vais si d'ananas sénat faire quand je le
fasse et maintenant ils voulaient vous
chalet voyez-vous crier au loup est pas
là on a un problème c'est que là mais
j'ai l'impression que shana madoff
j'ai l'impression que chaque indien
stikeman qui est quand même qui peut
paraître gros c'est à dire tous les
blancs sont racistes mettons entre on
peut danser dans ce style maintenant on
peut la difficulté à la vente d'ailleurs
j'ai fait un post à g à garmisch les
gens blancs égalera six points torga
sion je pense aussi que naby youla pour
obama puis il ya beaucoup de pauvres
hères j'ai vraiment fait pour ta bord de
la chicane ok je voulais amener tva
nouvelles chez moi et là tout le monde
commence et tout le monde avait lu le
livre pourquoi toute école ah ouais
c'est vrai de l'acheter
et bah katz vois ça ça veut dire que tu
parles aux convertibles mais c'est
normal parce qu'ils sont tous venus
après tout il ya quand même quelques
gens qui viennent aux mains d'hommes
mais dire des choses c'est aussi des
abonnés le mais ils viennent soit comme
aux non moi je pense que c'est dire ça
qui est raciste plein les abonnés qui
vont répondre à ma place quand elle est
écrite mais aussi la légende des
salaires d'autres gens qui viennent en
privé qui par là j'explique mais est ce
que je vais dire à temps pour rentrer à
cette idée là est ce qu'on peut dire que
si on dit tout le monde est raciste
est ce que c'est un steve mann qui fait
de chance aussi ça a du sens jusqu'à un
certain point dans son sous titre que
tous vont être jugés tout on n'a pas
force et jusque exemple dans l'échelle
de racisme tout mettant les noms on est
en dessous de comprend donc on peut pas
on avait vraiment de ce système qui nous
opprime et de notre côté ça compte pas
trop comme même s'il ya des gens mal
dans les facs et blanc comme pauvres est
un mariage non ça change de juste
préjugés ou jusqu'au luxe est vraiment à
cause du système est complet faux
comment on peut revoir à fait l'idée de
cette définition le canada se passe car
on en a toujours eu le
l'idée que c'était d'individus
individualités et moi je t'aime pas
personnellement parce que tu es noir et
pis c'est pas du tout ça en fait ceux
qui justement à ce que je pense que
met-on je pousse dans ce livre le haut
dans d'autres livres mais c'est si
d'autres notions que qui mettons que
j'ai entendu c'est que thomas est ce
qu'une personne noire prêtre assiste
sans aucun doute avoir des préjugés pas
voir toutes sortes de des billets
conscient ou inconscient après ce s
inscrit dans un système c'est ce qu'un
système raciste anti blanc
c'est sa mairie les uns disent oui mais
en afrique là c'était le seul blanc
étuvage comme l'afrique colonisée 7/1
l'afrique que leur argent vous riez faut
qu'ils prennent l'argent français
c'est cette afrique là je pense que les
blancs pas de pouvoir non mais tu es à
après sa pole et gates promène en
ferrari dans la rue le ça se pourrait
qu'il récuse ces blancs l'achat quand
même table pour possiblement que s'il y
avait un accord aussi grand que la
personne disposant ferrari c'est un noir
pendant qu'il aimerait pas plus non plus
c'est pas surtout sur tous et toutes les
pièces la ferrari c'est eux qui les ont
pris avec les enfants sous payés ils ont
tout favoris pas fait la rupture ould
comme avec l'opération mets tes après
ceux sur qui il a adressé à chaque pays
la dynamique est un dogme et y mettons
au québec au canada et aux etats unis
c'est une réalité fut bâti qui sont des
métiers qui ont peu plus concentré
là-dessus pitié l'argument de oui mais
le blanc d'afrique parce que c'est ont
menti vegan fois que c'est que moi
concentrons nous donc oui cet argument
l'amitié à chaque fois puisque les
enfants
[Rires]
mais non c'est sûr
exact est ce que est ce que tu es
comment tu te sens par rapport justement
à toute cette vague là qui est arrivé
avec le bloc live made la tribune qui
tacle la tribune en toi que grandit
énormément comment tu te sens par
rapport à ce toit qui parlait de ce
depuis des années qui faisait ton
contenu comme comme tu le faisais
c'est en parlant des enjeux qui quittent
importait puisqu'elle a soudainement
avec c'est comme une vague de personnes
qui tue qui recherche d'information en
suivant comment tu vis avec sait ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est positif pour
tous quelque chose que tu fais quand
même je trouve ça cool que mon temps on
m'écoute en écouter quand un peu 0 but
mes trucs mais je constate qu'il ya plus
de gens qui coûte
je suis aussi contente quand le truc qui
me rend le plus coton petit comme mes
amis m'envoient des trucs mans votre
formation qu'on trouve ailleurs comme
comme ça donc il faut pas juste ok alors
je folle au manoir
et puis je prends tout point
d'information la non comme iphone il
continue à lire des livres une faune
dessus sur son copain mais là j'ai lutté
lire ce que cela lui pour en parler
puisque sebo vrai j'adore ça sinon c'est
sûr que ça commence à devenir un peu de
pression parce que pour ça les gens
s'attendent à ce que tu fasses à 24
heures sur 24
tout l'enjeu des corps les gens je mets
des infos mais comme dans deux semaines
je menais seule fille comme tout le
monde
24 je suis bien dans ce segment b 0 oui
j'aime militer mais j'aime d'autres
choses plus comme la gagne dans une
semaine la camp de john est parti je
veux vendre des smoothies vivement aussi
la jungle ne faut pas non plus parce que
comme je peux respirer
des fois où sinon des fois c'est ce qui
me stresse c'est quand des hommes on
voit des trucs puis veulent là sont
fâchés que je ne lui pose pas vu ce
qu'obama dont j'apprends à 20,14 à 1,15
et une news comment ça je peux pas
besoin d'une pause
je fais pas comme média soit personne
qui m'envoient quelque chose qui juste
le tient je ne partage pas mais je suis
donc en un monstre je pensais pas que
c'était comme ça
comme quoi va donner sa table blanche là
toute évidence je vais leur demander de
lui pose voix bon c'est bon ça c'est pas
comme si c'est ma communauté sont là y
prendre sont là pour ça la plupart plus
comme ils ont sûrement déjà vu moi je
les ai vus dix fois je disparais pose
aujourd'hui va voir ce qui me touche pas
ce genre de personne c'est eux qui est
partie elle pas moi aubin l'engagement
c'est l'attaqué berry allait me est
moins bon fac et non j'ai partagé
l'époque de dire la vie de ton
personnage j'ai campana tchèque sujet
avec leurs personnages avec leurs
personnages que j'ai fait et je résume
parle de la fois où tu pris le contrôle
du instagram de karine st michel
c'est 1 2 3 à ce que parce que je m'en
souviens oui je m'en souviens de karine
créera plus contrôler c'est à lui qu'est
ce qu'elle avait dit puis je me souviens
que j'écoutais un peu ton podcast en a
parlé là dedans aussi mais je trouve ça
quand même intéressant comme phénomène
ce qui s'est produit
ça parlait même pas parlé mais je sais
plus non mais tu es dans le fond à te
prêter sa patente pendant quatre ans
puis ce qui est arrivé c'est qui georges
mille de ses abonnés qui ont huit cents
personnes qui sont passées comme ça ça
me choque mais son club
mais à quel point tu es pas capable
d'entendre parler de ce sujet le
programme après un cadrage est très
troublé hockey parce que je me sentais
mal parce que tu es mon but c'est de
parler à plus de gens pas briser sa
plateforme web therapy d'abonnés ensuite
ça m'a fait un peu voir une autre
perspective que moi ça
si même moi je t'ai gênant parlé mais
moi je te lâcher comme je m'explique au
jeu pendant un peu moins je vous parlais
regardez j'ai c'est une huile demain à
yann lavallez plus doucement ça je sais
quoi si même moi je vois si une
compagnie québécoise blacks comme que
votre entourage est carrément même un
copain d'alors d'abord comme un mets
regarde si si même mois première
principale concernée ce qui est commun
aux bêtes
il faut en parler - mais imaginez-vous
moi c'était vraiment troublé puis comme
pour vrai j'ai presque pas dormi ces
nullards des com pourquoi ça a vraiment
symbolique bien si c'est parce que tu
disais tantôt topo sur ta page des gens
qui y sont réceptifs 6 pi tiges loin de
le dire que si monsieur mais le le te
parle à des gens qui étaient quittes eux
ce n'était pas le pot avant de parler de
feu ou quoi que ce soit afin que ça de
les confronter plus que moi ce qui est
ce qui m'a plus choqué c'est plus qu'il
parte l'action de se désabonner puisque
tu veux juste ce qui peut la regarder
des story pendant 24 heures si profond
parce que c'est karine en plus que tu
pénalise mais pas moi enfin la journée
comme un style tout en conséquence de ne
pas entendre parler si ça va mieux je
suis pas entendre parler de ça il
voulait se faire mousser désabonner ses
sens car c'est ça moi qui m'a plus
choqué parce que maintenant je t'avais
un nouvel sont farcis résultat mes trucs
mais pour vrai moi je les vois pas rien
faire après fake jeu correct de
minuteries si je rentre chez nous puis
là je les vois partira quand même je la
mets au hockey et vivait vive et vivre
j'ai une interrogation par rapport à ce
rythme c'est qu'on en parle
durand t on à me parle souvent de
ensemble moi c'est quelque chose qui
quitte je crois que dans ceux où les
mouvements du social qui se passe en ce
moment dit que ce soit le blacklight
maroc ce soit la vague de dénonciations
que ce soit toutes ces choses là on
dirait que j'ai l'impression que le plus
important dit mettons si toi tu en
parles à toutes les plateformes
c'est super important sauf que le monde
qui sont stables at forme ces deux
mondes qui ont probablement déjà entendu
ce message le fait qu'ils veulent
vraiment continuer à étendre leurs
connaissances qui veulent continuer à
parler de thérapies puis a tué en même
temps pitié mais moi j'ai le feeling que
le monde qui ont besoin d'en entendre
parler le plus c'est vraiment le monde
qui sont le plus difficile à rejoindre
le temps l'exemple de toi qui t'es cover
un compte instagram de 45me chance
attaque vous avez pas le même casting
puis le monde qui te vois sur le compte
de karine qui se désabonnent kiss keep
la story ou kioua d'ever parce qu'ils te
vois touati
mais mon dirais que j'ai le filet de la
tribune le temps karine que sa tribune
le monde qui te suivent sur le temps
avant de parler car il c'est à eux qu'il
faut que tu parles si mais c'est dur à
rejoindre ce monde le masque quand vous
leur parlez de tsai se désabonnent puis
c'est comme les autres même chose avec
le podcast est on prêt chapeau
convertibles si je pense pas vraiment
que du monde qui nous suit au quotidien
ou à chaque semaine qui sont et qui ont
qui en importent sensiblement des mêmes
opinions politiques ou sociales que nous
autres il y en a peut-être qui changent
leur opinion au fil du temps puis qui
nous écoutent pour d'autres raisons mais
qui est-il mais je pense qu'on finit par
s'ennuyer pas mal mais là la question
c'est comment qu'on réussit à parler à
du monde tu veu pa cotation qui veulent
pas qu'on leur parti c'est simple c'est
ça le problème
et puis on m'a parlé alors qu'ils
conduisaient des clivages la société de
dire plus tu parles entendre que tu
restes loeb je tends ferme
comment qu'on fait à ce type pour faire
puis même chose de l'autre sens le truc
à la con fait pour mixer les discours
c'est parce qu'il faut pas qu'on vise le
côté opposé mais qu'on vise le milieu
enfin passé comme j'ai dit tantôt mois
que je me suis kanak doom une crise de
douze étoiles comme c'est vraiment j'ai
pour le show que je me découvre en fait
je pense que si on vise deux minutes
parce qu'il aimait tant
tous les gens qui viennent sur la place
en maintenant qu' ils sont là parce que
d'autres noirs
on propose neuf affaires qui connaît sa
peau d'un noir avant moi mais c'est
parce que carine mayau pose c'est parce
que jesse me reposer parce que tous les
blagues que je connais en fait comme où
une élève pertinente aujourd'hui et
cayman repartager que c'est là que les
gens m'ont vu et sont venus comprends
c'est pas si t'es pas entre nous qu'on
se devait d serge par exemple moi ces
exemples et je pas se connaissent et
renzan ashington annie morrissette aux
dés maintenant je partage cette rue qui
partagent les miettes on se partage sont
nos trucs mais là comme une limite de
gens qui vont faire le transmet pour
nous tout nous mêmes faits
même chose entre nous mais c'est quand
les gens extérieurs jeunes demain
mais je pense pas qu'on va rejoindre
vraiment les extrêmes extrême parce que
exemple si moi je partage vos trucs
si je suis jamais je connais des gens
qui sont comme jamais ces plateformes
c'est tout ce sont 2000 ils font comme à
bergues garde ils ont fait un pas ils
ont invité des gens ils ont parlé c'est
pas mal le milieu je pense qu'on devrait
civile mais parce que on est plus au
milieu en fait le con vu rejoint de si
jamais dans le québec tout le monde qui
est dans le milieu de vie entre à ceux
qui restent les douze la meute la 5ème
et la meute arrêter tant que chez vous
le coach est là mais les commentaires il
y est fait mais comme tu dis déjà rage
pour compenser il me semble qui sait où
je suis pas raciste même somme que sept
ans le mouvement le nahla n'a plus la
rive avec des bons arguments justes ce
côté mettons sont arrivés puis on y
place rien parce que leur a parlé c'est
le gars de la mutte ricard fait que ben
oui c'est vrai c'est sûr qu'être pauvre
hère faut que je les écoute plus encore
j'y crois pas qu'ils disent oui je pense
que t'en sais juste que cette personne
est allé vers un premier écart fait
quand même pas ben oui mais ensuite
quand tu as même quelqu'un d'autres
groupes bord la faune comme un live au
milieu mais bon encore là mais c'est les
gens qui sont vraiment au boubou et je
mange du coran par un monstrueux on
espère dans affaire puis quand même voir
que tout le monde change d'un côté blaye
volcom attend peut-être que je peux
avoir un petit peu de nuances
enfin m
un côté d'un bateau maintenant le milieu
du mans qui veulent rester accroché
finir par tomber la part tombé que le
bateau chavire c'est ça le changement de
pratique c'est l'équivalent au téléthon
à ce moment là justement avec ses les
conspirations pis les gens le contre le
masque pour le masque piloter l'espèce
de ces réseaux sociaux en ce moment ça
s'envoie chier beaucoup las une reprise
pas mettez en réalité le team et on lit
les conspirationnistes le endurci de
tisser ron minorité petits soucis qui
mettons système et la moindre petite
nuance yves on dira t elle tant
conspirant ciani est cependant c ou si
c'est le plot de montceau comme
clairement béton les affaires de
conspiration intense des réseaux de
wever de toutes les affaires les plus
flyé genre c'est exagéré mais genre et
on peut quand même question ici ou
douter de 600 gens n'ont plus accès la
marche du monde se trouve entre les deux
noté culte oui puisque béton par rapport
aux masques les gens il faudrait parce
que je comme je sais pas c'est quoi sa
chance qu'on soit pour ou contre il faut
juste le maître de la situation
le tarmac la finalité de la chose c'est
ça ça arrive vraiment si calais puis
surtout que je me dis à ce moment
j'étais pour les gens santé normal ça ne
s'est pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment
une très grande souffrance de porter le
masque alors dans sa marche pas ok mais
mettait vraiment rien à perdre à
lemaitre est juste mais je ne comprends
pas c'est pas une lutte de jeu comprend
la fin de droits et les libertés même
année là aussi contre les droits des
femmes mettant une musulmane parce que
bella il faut que s'habiller comme nous
aussi c'est ça les règles
ah oui maintenant les accès le masque à
mireuil changer quand les règles c'est m
contre les autres est resté correct il
fallait respecter les droits du québec
si vous avez si vous respectez la loi
vous feriez pas tabasser par la police
et méo qui me suit maintenant respecte
la loi mais non non
le mans le team terme et on s'est juste
aimer ton si chacun fait ses propres
règles c'est l'anarchie c'est parce
qu'ils les règlent 6e avec les
informations qu'on a eu on fait conforme
et des règles on y suit pitié on frôle
from any le post mortem de tupi on chez
crohas qui est ce que les règles étaient
les bonnes pièces que sa bonne façon
face aux quais si chacun fait ses
propres recherches
chacun va chercher son information
chacun dit moi je crois pas ce dont je
l'aimais pas puis moi je pensais pas que
je fais sur chacun fait sa propre
affaire mais ça marche pas fonctionné
comme ça la société sur tous il n'y a
pas vraiment de conséquences négatives
en france que si moi c'est ça mais ton
d'un match nous attend demain matin
l'esclavagé tout vous là ok il ya des
gens qui sauvent directement s'effectue
au point que je comprendrais pour ne pas
faire peser ce débat c'est la loi la
souffrance direct a des conséquences
directes exigent maintenant pis tu vas
pas souffrir quand j'ai pu mais tonton
économique sauf rien n'est plus mais
tout se passe rien n'est plus versus là
maintenant le mât c'est comme ça pas
souffrir dans matin là je trouve ça
c'est la chose qui me dérange le plus
c'est qu'on parle de six autres une
atteinte à mes droits et libertés c'est
quand même on t'empêche de rien avec un
match peut tout faire
je pourrais tu pourrais mettre un masque
puis allez dans des gang bang quand ya
encore des gang bang qui se passe le
genre d me des maisons dé changer ça et
ça existe encore jean paul ii qui
courait marathon sont minces mais ça se
peut même ça se fait
c'est comme tes droits tu veux aller
t'as pas il ya encore des gags mais des
groupes facebook et recyclés ou à
l'épicerie va l'être humain fac image
qui n'est pas on n'est pas en train de
dire en arrière du d'autobus le chasser
foulée ça me fait penser t on parlait
justement de de loi puis l'autoroute à
péage shocking puis mon nom était le
clou on se tait daalder et chantal en
titre inuit
j'y mets à ma défense je n'ai pas peur
parce que thil pileux ma famille tout le
monde est monde u20 correctement est
menée ce matin dans ma famille aucun
souvenir d'avoir entendu livrant des
propos que je me dis chiche assez
insistante obama arrive pas mais mettons
là c'était comme dans le pic de la
classe le moment tout le monde qu'il
fait je m'explique et le racisme
systémique si il est pas une loi dans le
code de loi qui dit tu dois discriminer
les noirs noté puis cissé qui puis je
comprends parce que je suis sûr qu'ils
ont lire permettant peut-être la loi sur
les métiers mettons sinon il n'y a pas
de jim crow là ici les pattes agrégation
il ya pas de loi déjà donc les racistes
systémique ce premier traitement peut
être aggravée avec celle de mai donc si
le racisme systémique mais possible
jeudi mais il a faim il comprenait hills
est dit il disait
du monde raciste mais disent comme spada
éloize pas un système
qu'est ce qui te réponds à samatan mais
c'est qu'il n'ya pas de loi contre le
racisme au fond fake
quelqu'un peut être ensuite une laisse
faire tout le temps parce qu'il ya pas
de loi compte parce que maintenant que
habito on dit oh mon dieu c'est vraiment
pas cool de discriminer quelqu'un dans
le logement à cause de son origine et la
plaint que le fond mais apparemment
conséquence tu le fais un chèque et
raciste qui s'est infectée comme fixe tu
veux engager quelqu'un se veut ne pas
engager quelqu'un parce qu'il est noir
pu le faire il ya personne qui va donner
on sait pas quel âge et de tout va dire
ah ben il était moins qualifiés abello
t'avais loach avait plus de grandes que
notre vie et j'avais j'ai préféré
sunrise a préféré son vin mais bien
trois diplômes mais lui a préféré son
weid et personne n'a trouvé quelque
chose cloche
mais il ya loin marc c'est son
entreprise et/ou fait qu'il n'ya pas de
lois qui empêchent le racisme alors
réclamé une personne qui est raciste
puis on a conclu tout à l'heure que tout
le monde les terres j'imagine j'attends
donc je vais je vais l'appeler disait
était même mettant par rapport à la
police on s'inquiète profilage racial
quant à savoir été dénoncée s'arrête pas
et toujours pas de règle fekter
concluons pas fait des documentaires
l'actif documentaire l'action n'a pas de
documentaire suisse et swisscom s'est
classé et c est bien ça change toujours
pas dit quand je parle aux gens sont
encore eu 100 comme non mais ça existe
pas vraiment revue l'agera cela puisse
composer cap sinon c'est pas du
profilage racial ceux du profilage cela
et cette union sexy qui tu n'y es pas ce
qu'on va voir ce que le hoodie kenpo
clown ni on sait que c'est pas les
blancs dans les routes dis que tu vas
chercher
non mais je comptais vous dit tout mon
secondaire monsieur j avais fait
intercepter par une personne ne vous dis
pas reçu à temps les écouteurs que je
m'affaire base y'a personne qui veut
manger
pourtant tu avais le profil selon m
alors pour ça
dans le soir dans une rue comme on dit
c'est juste que le système laisse le
racisme contre les pistaches des atouts
- chamakh et qui me dit ça existe pas le
racisme c'est lui systémique que la loi
sur les indiens c'est noir sur blanc
ouais ça l'a souligné loi sur les aides
yates pécunier pauvres hères ait encore
des gens qui me disent mais bon l'été
passé
je m'étais fait volume qui est du japon
la police puis modifiez témoin c'est
tous des noirs des arabes
c'est la prévarication ok elle s'est
fait rentrer dedans dans son auto bas
matrice dont la cavale s'est fait un
très bon même auto plus et ça ils
demandent à ce que vous avez vu le
conducteur non mais le chauffeur d'un
autre question question os qui te noies
mais je n'ai pas vu je n'ai pas vu ce
qu'il s'est vraiment ça fait chic comme
mais pourquoi ce serait un réflexe donc
cette personne la corse va dire qui mais
c'est raciste madame mais est-ce qu'il
va assurer que 500 emplois maintenant on
a besoin de vacances garder son emploi
pour continuer à propager ça tout le
monde
puis c'est nous qui paie les
conséquences à l'instar des bagarres
stadium tout va bien il est supérieure à
20 à taux courants peut-être comme non
maîtrisé
la prochaine fois elle fera plus mais
continue il avait pas que la prochaine
fois le frapper c'est le président a
répondu vraiment que sur chaque question
tout le temps au cesag au touquet la
personne qui fait la même taille que tu
devrais de 30 ans parle il ya un j'en ai
les français il sort un livre l'oeil
dans le fonds jeunesse indépendant qui
fait une infiltration puis filtrer la
police française pendant deux ans ça
doit être égal 2 ha oui ils sont en
cours d'année policiers trois mois trois
mois tu supportes gone pete est
peut-être qui peut arrêter des gens peut
visiter il raconte des histoires des
justes langage qui trie centre d'autres
c'est ultra 6 litres sexistes au sein du
corps de police du corps et pas d'un spi
s'est dit d'aider des jeunes go été
tabassées par la police puis le tout le
monde s'est battu tout le monde fait un
four rapporter dit gilles dussault teddy
attendant l'entrevue le c'est comme ça
ça fait mal c'est pas beau le tri après
ce encore une fois autre pays autre
réalité mais je dire on peut facilement
penser que les choses peuvent arriver
n'importe où le thé puis avait dit que
big time dans sa caserne l'ubs ce genre
c'est le monde était qu'étaient apparus
de manière publique sa balle envoyée ce
que disait pitt il y avait tout un autre
aussi un autre avant la médaille sur son
son infiltration c'était que les
policiers villon un mal-être est immense
les dix que le taux de suicide chez les
policiers en france est vraiment élevé
que les gens sont vraiment beaucoup de
juste deux policiers souffrent depuis
juin était une façon soin de leurs
conditions de travail sont vraiment
media group est celui qui sait peut-être
d'accueillir une façon de d'un exutoire
quelconque où justement il ya le sens
certains empruntent sur mal à l'aise
avec ses failles et se dit que c'est
tellement la culture de hausse bac qui
était son ex compagne il adapte moi je
passe moi je pense vraiment que c'est si
je pense qu'une grande majorité et
policiers doivent pas être très correct
puis vouloir le mieux c'est ce que je
pense moi je pense très grande majorité
sont vains car aix et jusque là un
problème c'est qu'il la majorité bac la
minorité qui pas grec dlc ça pour son
confort c'est comme si tout le monde
quittait suis pas raciste mais est
injuste anti raciste
on aurait pu ne rien y aurait pu être
moi parce qu'ils paient aussi ils se
disent ah mais c'est en tant que le
policier que si tu ne bat pas les gens
qui partent à jobs fiq
c'est sûr que c'est pour ça que la
solution c'est vraiment de défendre pour
lui
hier la gagne c'est clairement c'est pas
certaine de police marche pas vraiment
on en a parlé avec guy bono des bois qui
est venu ici le cpie lui qui s'était dit
fin de police c'est quand même je pense
un un slogan qui nous provient des états
unis donc tu es je pense faut quand même
faire attention de pour reprendre toutes
les idées les appliquer puis il
appliquer sa pensée ce que ça
s'appliquera réellement ici mais il ya
une chose qui je pense qu'ils surent ici
qui fonctionne pas c'est que la police
va intervenir dans des cas dans lesquels
sont pas formés aux méthodes et des
brins de santé mentale ou trop
d'épreuves képi puissesseau pic larmor
jeudi aux états unis l'ont le voit qu'un
réel problème d'éthique à brindisi qui
était la police et ultra army militarisé
un point excessif le puits que la
remercie mais ton ton premier réflexe
pour maîtriser quelqu'un c'est lui tiré
sept balles dans le dos et qui après
maintes informations clés d'europe et le
maîtriser mais sinon c'est comme chez
textuel armes à feu ce samedi m
c'est vraiment envie de remettre
l'argent mais les fonctions de santé
mentale on voit pas la police
on peut donner la raison travailleur
social qui fait que c'est pas tant parce
qu'on veut juste enlevé leur drapeau de
sérémange les maths ailleurs parce que
ils n'ont pas d'affaires a toujours
répondants premier exemple
en fait ils ont en fait la grande
majorité du temps c'est faux ça devrait
pas des policiers
c'est la grande majorité je pense que
ces braquages de banques en deux ans
plus tard social d'une équipe qui est
prête pour un bagad le banc mais tant
qu'on parle qu'on parle plus de toit -
de saucière donc on parle de toi
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu fais ces
jours-ci camatte occupe t journée
j'attends toujours et pour des années a
atteint 5 en décembre
des journées qui parle beaucoup
d'efforts mais là je sais pas ce que
vous en avez accès juste pour savoir
comme ça j'ai droit de mentir
la question des journées mais sinon
c'est pas absurde est capable maintenant
de ce que tout cas pas de plus de ceux
déjà ta g ouais nan je pense pas non
plus la cas q mais je pense pas mais
comment est-ce que tu seras tu as une
toiture un travail ni fan ça fait
combien de temps c'est une nouveau
projet de campus a fait un temps fait ça
mais j'ai pu manger un manque de photos
mais pendant qu'on fait moi mais ça
avant mais pas sur une femme de conduire
ça ma job mais portent le savait parce
que clairement j'allais pas moi c'est
toi qu'est ce que c'est ça ta job dessus
continue j'y vois comment parler tant
par les fêtes pleine mais le projet
peinent à parler après a parlé mais ce
fut le point paru un peu le pendant
parfait mais j'ai demandé des photos du
comique assad mais ça fait quand même
longtemps que j'ai ça sauf que tu es ce
que c'était sur 17 c'est déjà sur ton
propre compte le monde décrivait puis s
est plus souvent pour ce match at t
shirt nappe sata et
commente ceux des particuliers qui tu es
et puis lui demander une vidéo tout le
monde trickett personnalisés et c'est
simple il a maintenant on y forme
c'était plus parce que pendant qu'on
finance et du genre la mode de l'écrit
comme maintenant que tout le monde se
créer un compte de deux semaines en
haïti parce qu'il ya des gens qui s'en
sort mais pas sur l'autre puis pour
comme sa valeur de devenir maman
mainstream c'est comme monter et là on
en a marre là s'était fâché bon effet
que j'arrêtais de moi pour moi ça fait
longtemps je fais ça ça fait déjà huit
tamm ha tamm a reçu à la poterie pull à
ben écoute elle m'a dit qu'ils allaient
y paraît la bonne nouvelle oui c'est ça
elle ne peut pas habiter chez elle
maintenant témoins de jéhovah la gagne
le site côte et quand est ce pour ça moi
en parler ça me va c'est juste une
semaine pour elle s'il n'y a pas de
système ils apprennent
est-ce que parloir avec outre le
sans-fil podcast maintenant le google
des fois ne soit plus qu'attendu
c'est bon c'est pour ça que la science
est trop long et femmes mais en même
temps je dois te fait des vidéos youtube
par en fait ouais mais c'est ça qui a
réussi ce que je pensais pas qu'elle
regardera ce point là puis là j'ai la
vidéo après d'enfants que je suis
j'avais pas mis avant la gelée dit sur
instagram aa je me trouvais drôle de la
pasta g ensuite m
ma le lendemain je lui ai annoncé mon
jeu vers la maison payée comme la suite
mais des photos sur internet place comme
on dit ce qu'il avait déjà signé
oui là j'explique j'explique paix comme
non mais c'est pas vraiment ça je parle
lâche commun elle avait une photo c'est
instagram
- mer au coucou chico c'est clair j'ai
gardé au secret pendant huit ans et
c'est comme ça que je me fais cela l'a
fait là moi je leur ai parlé à ma
famille il ya deux semaines environ
puis maintenant expliqué que comme ça la
surprend pas vraiment mia longtemps moi
j'ai oublié la pige pas vraiment de
mémoire de mes amis mon temps peut-être
neuf ans justement en lien avec des
photos que j'aurais mis quelque part l
heure est diamé part à neige comme ouais
ça fait vraiment pense que ça sauf
qu'avant j'étais bénévole
maintenant je jouais lui c'est la guerre
cvc ça à chaque fois les gens sont comme
un homme était tout sympa genre
objectifs ou quelque chose comme ça
c'est comme les gens font ce qu'ils
veulent à quelques photos moi tout ce
que je sais c'est que avant que j'arrive
thunder défilé gay demandez nous devons
de nous gratuit mon âme et mon loyer
sait qu'il a plus objectif et là dedans
mais non c'est aussi quelque chose qui
dérangeait pas la base afin non c'est
sage avait un problème avant un problème
la voix hier partout à tout le monde
[Musique]
l'aveo facteurs mais comme non pas tout
le monde c'est juste défendu par la capi
en photo puis convoqué jeté une bonne
can avant j'étais encore peu connu mais
je t'avais satan imagine tu prenais frei
chaque fois
à chaque fois parce que dans ce sens là
mais je n'ai pas comme ça je vais dire
supprimer chaque fois fait pas les
oreilles et en mettant ma soeur après
parce que ça mon prénom c'est à la ligue
arabe
maintenant j'ai moins quatre ou cinq
photos c'est dans ce sens là à lui
chavez mais bon il peut faire ce qu'il
veut avec aime bien quand même confiance
que les gens ne partagerait pas mais bon
puis là j'ai fait un jeu temps d'un long
métrage là qu'il va sortir un jour ces
communes de laisser sortir picoler quoi
m
le bruit des moteurs de philippe
grégoire mais c'est pourquoi oui
j'accepte ça se peut qu'ils aiment
scènes de nu ou pas parce qu'on l'a
filmé comme deux fois par an vers
laquelle ibm et maintenant je suis torse
nu il est comme ça c'est un gros écran
de toutes mes matches tender ils ont
déjà vu mes seins si pauvre est rendu là
comme ça et je me casse ça va sortir
amman 9 partis s'y mettent c'est que ya
plus de jeunes c'est comme s'ils
devaient être pudique c'est trop tard
c'est déjanté c'est comme clairement
pour voir au début cela sans raison que
j'avais arrêt en fait j'ai fait ça
pendant un an comme bénévole à temps
pour ça je me suis dit mais c'est parce
que comment à n'importe quel moment ils
pourraient décider de les sortir pour me
faire chier tu es rendu là pour se
battre et profite pas si quelqu'un
voulait facile en fait à tout moment
plan maintenant mais tant que les 10 500
grammes les gens dans la vie savent bien
qu'elles sont vraiment sortis faire s'il
tue à le sortir pour faire quoi pour la
donner gratuitement
comment certains sujets comme à ok quand
ça me fait vraiment me faire chier ses
débuts savais pas vraiment ce que
j'avais ma carrière parce que c'est tout
le monde le sait maintenant que tu me
point dans son film en sachant que je
fais ça moine on s'en fout si quelqu'un
montre une photo de m com - c'est pour
ça que c'est pour ça que c'est un petit
bond depuis cacher tant mieux pour toi
bien dans le fond que j'ai une amie qui
est une amie une connaissance qui a fait
l'expérience
connaissances je pense que je connais
qui fait l'expérience ce quelqu'un puis
essayer ce qui est un plus pour
l'expérience le vécu l article dans le
fond là dessus sur comme son expérience
d'affaires ce qui est un début a tripé
petits crimes crimes sur soi des soupirs
petit quand même je dis c'est comme
substantielle le parfois je trouve que
pour savoir mais amener petit le jeu
passe ses propres à chacun d'y aller
comme développer une espèce de justement
à trouver qu'à profiter de gens qui
étaient vulnérables restent sens mal
mais la ceni a pu avoir de fans mais il
peut le jugement dans ma question se
pose est que si des gens qui sont
frappés et charles pour une photo le sud
c'est comme une espèce d'éclat dans un
sens c'est à mais il ya des gens que
c'est ça qui disait que c'était tout ce
que je n'ai pas su gérer comme
vulnérables et des gens qui aiment
facteurs-clés faut y en a qui leur soit
donné de l'argent comme leurs réseaux de
leur plaisir à la vie s'était donné
l'argent qui comme tu leur dis comment
dépenser que ce qu'a dit ah oui paye ton
loyer envoie moi un virement interac épi
achètent des souliers la femme comme il
aime ça comme c'est ça qu'il je sais que
c'est leur triple à si jamais quelqu'un
dans le public qui veut que ce garçon
insensible à l'école a menacé mais têtue
comme moi comme ex pense pas qu'il soit
abîmé moi je moi je vois pas vraiment
comme vous tenir à bhl et sk est ce que
me demande des fois
est-ce que tu as du monde des fautes tu
leur parles de ton sur ton et les femmes
ce fait comme et c'est pas quelqu'un qui
a un qui est longue liste à quelqu'un
qui quitte
qu'ils arrêtent besoin de quelque chose
d'autre que semer ton ressenti ça date
non je te demande trop aux besoins
définis trop bizarre mais non mais
défend pas le foot et bloque à il y
avait une fois monsieur fall à 7 ans
mais comme je les comprends mais par des
gens c'est qu'en fait comment moi je les
voyais tous et qui ils ont regardé pour
nous sommes là gratuit sauf que là à la
place in type c'est qu'on prend comme si
tu pourrais tu achèteras le club de bord
chez toi mais tu vas dans un bar la
barre mais est ce que est ce que tu
comment je peux formuler ces questions
est ce que met-on justement c'est parce
qu'il y ait quand même la différence
entre avons l'impression de est-ce que
tu formes un lien avec les gens qui ont
aucune qui s'abonnent sur ton iphone
c'est parce que maintenant moi je vois
sur point l'homme je regarde la pointe
but aucun lien avec eux dit ok c'est ça
moi les personnes qui considèrent que
les han tu vois ça ça peut-être qu'elle
avait des gens vulnérables
il ya des gens qui voient les messieurs
comme juste des portefeuilles ça
m'intéresse de moi parce qu'on prend sa
mère sociale parce que comme weedon
l'argent mais justement pas l'abbé
gratuit c'est pas juste parce qu'il veut
voir des photos je dressais parce que tu
es toi qui veux theft auto école sociale
des gens qui qui les voit juste comme de
l'argent puisque ont bien en tout cas
moi je pense qu'il a vécu mais j'étais
là qu virtuellement m'attend je parle
depuis si je prends dans nouvelle est
tout même les marins
quand j'ai arrêté les deux mois parce
que ma mère était facile il y en a tous
les jours le jeu met à crier we point de
mes nouvelles qui savait que j'étais
pris sa caméra terracher blabla qu'on
veut juste parler comme puis pendant
cette demande j'ai arrêté je n'ai jamais
demandé d'argent gary jamais rien si sa
vanité comme un métier regarde tout
commander du berry t il j'ai pas mis de
photos gériez miss estime envoyé parce
que c'est tenter ce moment-là que j'ai
rien demandé à personne chic bon genre à
tout le monde blanc de désabonnez vous
pour pas que je m'approchais savoureux
flash
ouais parce que je clip j'ai pu mettre
nos photos faites pauvres à payer pas
brouiller la gâte rien quelque chose
qu'en fait comme un non mais c'est vrai
qu'on va rester à bonne et ça va t'aider
je suis comme ok mais bon bref je pense
pas que j'ai l'impression que j'habite
deux leur dit avant de partir tout en
restant dans les centres de cause fait
monsieur tout le monde
il est préfacé un prof décision ça c'est
dans les deux mois qui te prennent pas
aux soins
j'étais revenue je revenais infraforces
mais il ya des que le tgv on a entendu
parler le mot jusqu'au 9 août c'est
qu'il a fait pisser comme je connais pas
mais là exactement des cas où est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui abusent vraiment
le ton franchie c'est quoi le son j'ai
pas fait nous résumer l'histoire et les
gens comme ça mais les gens qui veulent
juste volé les autres un pourriel ok
j'arrête taille elles sont actrices
vedettes américaines puis à l'ope assez
ouvert la défense puis elle a promis une
nous d'un échange de genre 200 pierre
davant ce qui commence à marcher que tu
peux envoyer des messages qui sont
bloquées a pris le mettons maintenant
moi j'envoie mes tantes watts une
demande quelque chose mais je la vois
que moi je trouve considère ça coûte 50
pièces mais je mets la photo puis je
peux mettre un prix dessus et que toi
quand tu reçois tu veux juste voir comme
un cadenas qui décrit 50 $ pour
débloquer et qui paient dans 54 ensuite
tu vois ma photo ap après ce fait elle a
fait ça avec une photo d'eux sans
appellation ces trois photos elle face à
200 dollars mickey non ça fait j'en ai
même pas ce qu'était censé être exempt
que je saurai tout nu dans ses photos
voilà
puis elle est d'abord puis creek avec le
feu mais on est femme ils veulent pas
vraiment que je fasse carmes
alors tu me faire rembourser jusqu'à
maintenant c'est clair
disons que 450 personnes qui demandent
un remboursement de 200 pièces serov
fait que non ce moment peu plus jamais
rien mais table 200 pièces le maximum
ses 50 qu étaient toutes les personnes
que c'est notre revenu pour vrai ouais
ça vient de tout brisé dans un sens ou à
temps je décide je vais faire un film de
20 minutes ou l'allemande 200 pièces là
je fais plus mais c'est vrai maintenant
tu veux faire une job
lâcher de nous révéler tout juste pu le
faire tous fait de quoi deux fois cinq
ans que tu faisais le ton moi je n'avais
rien mis autant mais j'aurais aimé
médias tant l'idée de dire parce que le
taiso la révolte hic c'est quelque chose
qui existe avec l'idée de dire est que
j'aimerais ça pouvoir faire de quoi il
veut combiner ce que j'aime faire piller
mettons ta passion pour le cinéma outils
lighting de pouvoir faire ça me semble
que sans que ce je vois ça comme
vraiment je réfléchis à voir dans ce
moment aucune liste des l'utilisation de
faire de quoi de plus artistique de plus
mes deux titres de fermer le monétisant
sûr parce que j'aime secret se défend
militants tous et en même temps parce
qu'on vous en tickets mais monsieur qui
s'en sort une femme sont pas là pour
militer pas à tout ça pour être cédés
des niaiseries comme ça c'est des pics
atteints pourquoi ça a vraiment quand
même ce qu'a fait beaucoup de choses
puis surtout que met-on l1 ni kaki bella
thorne qu'il ya un million de personnes
qui sont abonnées à arm a besoin de
mettre de photos puis 110 pièces par
mois ça pèse parce que des millions par
exemple je suis ravi c'est ça moi je
suis là c'est comme ces dix clients qui
rentrent ponctuelles qui sortent quito
je suis pas assuré d'avoir eu 100 fans
du sens fans 3000 fans à chaque mois ça
veut dire que faut que faut quasiment
j'en profite de plus possible il faut
que j'achète je cours je te convaincre
le plus possible de rester plus
longtemps possible ce combat faut que tu
en vois des trucs que tu veux vraiment
écopent d'amendés l'ena je reste parce
que sinon les gens pourraient qui
cherche quand même tgcom j'ai mon
préféré non mr clients et tous que j'en
dis dacoury tabley a plein les fans
gratuit puis il y a trois filles paye
seulement play on y va tout en les fans
ziggurat dessus pour sa bonne j'aurais
dû tuer un fossé ce que je conseille à
tout le monde de faire si jamais je
devais donati tauriel aux gens faites
vous
faisant deuxième attaque et gratuit
incubé ya celui qui est gratuite mais
tout mais censuré fait le monde faut
qu'ils payent par photo par photo puis
aussi c'est plus facile de dire aux gens
qui sont sur instagram houleuse jour
d'aller sur un autre gratuit que d'aller
payer tout de suite là il peut voir le
genre de truc que tu m'aies pis ils
veulent payer par mois peuvent si un
mois - doivent plus bas et vous retourne
chez lucky qui est payé par mois au
toutes les photos sont débloquées toutes
les photos sont débloquées tout à fait
vu tous mes photos messages privés
c'est ça sauf les pauses est prévu que
tu peut débloquer mais c'est que tu peux
tu peux tourner autour de ça dans le
sens de parce que tu bouges de tout
mettre non plus des gens qui n'est pas
du tout le point dans leurs films pour
ce métal abonnement s'agace par mois
mais ton exemple parce que c'est un
exemple mais tomber m sur mon instagram
du mais trois photos sûrement sur mon
iphone gratuite mais peut-être une
quatrième photo puis je fais je me pris
pour débloquer le real puis sûrement ils
sont censurés partout puis sûrement
payant mais dont je mets trois photos
mais non censurée mais quand j'en ai 12
mai 3 fortement ce samedi comme à type x
dollars pour avoir le reste comme ça
fait classe il laisse un type comme ça
tu pas bloquer du mal mais ils peuvent
les satyres me renvoie les autres autour
des choses comme ça puis lequel les deux
ans les fans c'est le plus rentable et
en ce moment pour moi
si le payant celui qui paie un par mois
pour ma cellule et les plus payants mais
pour vrai les deux poulpes pourrait
vraiment être payant et toupie je pense
je me force pas tant gratuit kz1 donc
j'aimerais vraiment fou plus mais force
est parce que j comme trois fois plus de
fans en gratuit donc j'ai trop faible de
chance de trucs mais quand je dis que
bon j'essaye vraiment mon but n'a envie
c'est vraiment pas de crosse et les gens
inquiets fait qu'ils suivaient y
participent comme demande là je fais
aussi dans le monde mais se venge comme
j'allais voir ce qui les sérieux
est-ce que ce que tu te considères comme
ce soir qu est ce qu est un terme que tu
considère qu'il ya des préjugés face à
travailleuses du sexe mais sa légende
bon allez social qu'anthony fall mais
oublie grillades prenable la fiabilité
est un robot il était là explique que tu
donnes à pau nord depuis maintenant
s'abonnent à premium à point nommé pour
une crise de scène tu vois que la figure
comme le résultat est le même temps près
de l'action la zone est tactile et même
nom de kleenex
sauf que là c est pas été payé à sa
juste valeur et là maintenant moi je
suis moi puis l'argent sa juste valeur
c'est déjà super tabarnak de payer cinq
pièces par mois et quand je dis c'est
simple à ce moment mais t'as pas accès à
tout ce que je dis mais c'est vraiment
accès à ce contenu
mais comme je dis ce matin je mets une
photo non censurée puis je dis aux pays
affectés pouvoir des fois des gens ils
s'abonnent indiqué qu'un cinquième a
besoin à mendier mais s'il n'y avait pas
quelque chose que ça mais ce que sa
pièce par mois c'est un peu pour ça non
mais dans le titre c'est hypocrite et
mes tongs et qu'elle critique l'oreille
et nayla fait ce canal qui checke
d'appoint de noix par jour se piquer au
jeu qui même les filles aussi
justement comme jeudi avant qu'on me
wade nous gratuit on a fait la même
action prendre une photo de nos seins
dans le miroir moi j'ai 25 pièces like
même lady gaga en famille parce qu'on a
une fille et où j'ai perçu un homme sans
solliciter ça c'est cela c'est toujours
moi hier soir
ça n'est plus gratuite pizza je reçois
mes son iphone j'en attends tu me
regardes appelle le dic writing qui
donne tu y vas tu évalues tu donnes une
note expliquant que la note bien rodée
pas bien vu que tu les payes pour ça que
tu es abonné travail lors des pics le
temps qu'il paye 40 places pour se
retrouver cet article non mais c'est 1,6
million dont 17 dans leur découverte est
faite moi ton truc moi j'écris mon
message block c'est cela sa relation
souvent chaque jour du monde qui sont
prêts à payer 7 de leur peau le juge
lord et dans les vallées de la ccsa fêté
pour la même chose on est les deux
filles on a envahi la sphère north end
explique j'ai fait 25 pièces et cette
pièce tu as fait
riguet oui par rapport à par rapport aux
éléphants dont il avait parlé à
quelqu'un que lisa à venait d'ouvrir son
divin on n'a pas la cachant mosquée ce
qu'ils ont déjà de la mesure puisque
j'ai réussi à réfléchir plus longtemps
plus largement par rapport à lison
depuis son enfance mais tant pis moi ce
qui me dérangeait ou du moins de ce à
quoi j'avais jamais un marais c'était le
fait que sur sa plate forme personnelle
instagram à part des montants d'argent
de comment faisait du cash qui commence
à pouvoir être attrayant pour son fort
lointain de modeste mon malaise résidait
le encourager les gens à le faire de me
dire de d'imaginer mettons là c'est ça
une jeune femme qui suit disant qu'ils
voient comme un film d'une jeune fille
qui voit comment
ça peut rapporter de l'argent comment
c'est attrayant surtout ceci mis en
rapport avec le fait que j'ai pas
vraiment jugement piqué j'ai rien à dire
sur comment une femme vêtue au nord puis
deux mais on dirait que mon malaise par
rapport à ça et pas partie si justement
pourquoi est ce que toi tu parce que toi
je sais maintenant c'est à plateforme
tant par le pote je te propre plateforme
en parle un tout petit peu mais il n'y a
aucune
si j'avais eu aucune référence à de
l'argent ou un montant fait ça mais je
sais pas me ma pensée pas abouti par
rapport à ce sujet de l'hamza parce que
d'un côté je me dis tout le monde sait
bien ce qu'ils veulent avec l'homme en
forme
une bonne façon de monétiser du contenu
c'était pas les acteurs or le b2 pour
toi
de l'autre côté on dirait que sur une
plateforme qui est plus fidji ou est-ce
que tu atteins des 14 à 20 ans on dirait
que j'ai de la misère à avoir zappé à me
dire à me dire good ces puits suite à ce
titre vous à la presse à lille on doit
ça fait un test boîte qu'elle a pas
parlé de son effet de l'argent qui a
fait avec pitié par parfait le fais ce
que tu veux à partir de l'autre mais
c'était l'homme moi j'avais ma raison
devrait chez je comprends le truc c'est
que par rapport à nos jeunes et tout
c'est que c'est tellement pas anodin
c'est vraiment pas juste comme je me
suis pas grave je suis plus d'arranger
enlève l'instant c'est parce que là
c'est en ligne pour toujours faire la
décision
que tu prends une décision tu peux
prendre de bonnes rentes à vie
tabarnak à peu revenir longtemps que
tout le monde sait ne peuvent pas des
savoirs ses passages à parle un peu
moins ces mêmes patrons parce que j'ai
peur que tout le monde a pour sa voix
juste ça ouais mais moi je suis là j'ai
fait je fais des films chez des vidéos
je fais c'est ça après ça c'est juste
ouais elle lui fait tout ce que tu veux
dire vont être tentées par quelqu'un que
j'avais gabarnac sont nos clients c'est
exactement ça c'est pour ça en fait que
j'en ai pas parlé pendant huit ans des
vraies affaires
puis quand les gens ne coûtaient
méthadone pour douter de ce que je dis
il a maintenant clairement les gens qui
arrivent même un pécule savons comme
douté parce que tu attends je commets
tous en latin doutait pas que je vends
mes 500 internet que je lis au moins
deux livres j'ai plus de temps pour lire
des livres mais n'en tue pas c'est
minimum ça se fait moi mon problème
quand tu as conscience en plein en
pleine conscience la décision du prince
faut réfléchir l'otan c'est ça quand
même quand c'était vieille août est
vieux c'est passé juste qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de monsieur qu'ils font
mais comme il faut réfléchir
lantin puis site la raison de le faire
c'est l'argent pourquoi cette api raison
quand c'est quoi l'agencement c'est
juste moi j'aime ça en fait je me sens
forte mais comme je lui fais ça gratuit
aussi puis j'aime la relation que j'ai
avec les clients j'aime j'aime que ce
soit ça mon travail au lieu d'aller
faire autre chose parce que ton âme
10ème étape laisse à penser le bronze
chez les autres choses comment pas
autant mes vidéos youtube comme quoi
j'aurais pas ton argent ça fait huit ans
que ça vous saviez pas alors certains
jettent potentiel pour tous mais j'ai
fait aussi les autres choses sauf que
faire ça ça me donne plus de temps enfin
les autres ce que je veux faire parce
que si je devais travailler 40 heures
quelque part puis juste pouvoir payer le
minimum mais je pourrais pas faire les
autres ce que je veux faire je veux lire
beaucoup de livres moi mon but dans la
vie mondaine ambitieux et étudiants
toute la vie je comprends que je
travaille 40 heures mais moi non plus
mais si je fais ça je peux continuer à
faire d'autres choses infinies appui à
toutes sortes de job aussi que tu peux
faire c'est ce que moi ça m'intéresse
travail sexe j'aime ça c'est ce thème
sont carrément donc le la motivation de
façon numéro un
pourquoi quelqu'un voudrait des
travailleurs travailleuses du sexe c'est
[ __ ] des maisons travail d'enfants si
oui le jeune patient comme la brigade
parce que si tu le fais pour l'argent je
peux faire pour la présence ici pour
l'argent aussi
huguette aussi peut-être leur choix
carrière parce qu'aux fins et enfin il
se rend compte qu'ils n'ont pas de
médecin mais qui boit pas leurs enfants
c'est là que tu risque plus de se faire
exploiter puis de regretter parce que
exemple moi je fais ça pour le plaisir
sexton manque quelque chose qui pendant
mes limites lettre comme bahnou parce
que ça m'amuse rappaz de le faire mais
si je suis là parce que puis je dis ça
même pour les personnes en situation
précaire plus précaires comme si c'est
parce que tu as besoin de ce 20 dollars
la tête va considérer à des passes tes
limites
ah ouais parce que c'est 20 de la rade
en a besoin la fin du mois tandis que
moi pourtant la fin du mois je
ouvrir mes maisons mais au début du mois
valeur comment comme moi je sais que
j'aime faire ça donc je peux pas
vraiment me brimés dans ce que je fais
parce que sinon ça n'amuse pas même
temps tu sais jusqu'où tu es prête à
aller pis tu ne passeras pas pour
l'argent
exactement mais ça c'est ça arrive juste
quand t'es pas là que pour l'argent
parce que quand il ya une limite que tes
passions de vouloir blâmer besoin pour
justement 2 100 piasses techau atteinte
à la fin en photo c'est pas quelque
chose que tu veux qu'il soit sur
internet nulle part mais 2 100 piasses
une photo comme pour vrai tout le monde
y pense comme telle attaque en hockey
mais exemple moi je sais qu'ils
attendent 200 pièces une valeur est là
pour l'argent et les questionnements ça
soulève dix ans et que on se dit c'est
ce est suivi par des jeunes alors une
influence t qu'elle veuille ou non non
c'est sûr mais c'est correct qu'elle
veut par contre est prise et responsable
que tu le veuilles ou non un emploi sur
des jeunes qui qui qui quitta de mérite
dans la hotte même des fois qu'ils
prennent en exemple donc mais est ce que
c'est un mauvais timing de dire va
devrait pas en parler parce que ça va
influencer les jeunes est ce que ça
contribue à stigmatiser le sexologue
faut pas six mois même temps ce
qu'aurait qu'on ne parle pas des ados de
sex work qui y prendre leur décision
plus tard je pense qu'il faut on leur en
parler mais avec intelligence choqué
parce que justement ils ont 16 ans mais
ils vont quand même office open up exact
qu'on prend c'est impossible de bloquer
leur site web leur brasero complet trop
d'euphorie les sensibiliser à que
caillons 18 puis l'argent bonnes cartes
de crédit ils vont à l'encourager les
filles directement au lieu de point de
robe zippée à les faire aller ya
d'autres sites locaux jusqu'à puis mais
comme c'est notre site de deux points
mais plus loin de comprendre ce que je
pense qu'il faut leur en parle il faut
juste trop simplifier les choses mais
justement tout le monde est comme un de
mes gens vers les fans peuvent être
riches non
côté lisons de nadau picards n'ont pas
ramassé pas dans le facile parce que
c'est un peu comme un tambour se
placeront cela fait dix ans
internet fait payer maintenant cette
plateforme affectant mieux si ça marche
pour bret tant mieux parce que toutes
ces années de bénévolat fera pas cet
argent le sait sur mon fils je suis
qu'un qui peu connu sur instagram où
tout est faux mais c'est tout à fait pas
dur parce que les gens qui sont pas dans
les réseaux sociaux on sait dans nous ne
passerons la bonne manière de se
promouvoir
c'est maintenant le temps de la descente
à g c'est tout pas de là j'ai quand même
s'abonner premiers mois mais je suis
abonnée fait je sais pas si elle fait
des chaleurs avec d'autres filles mais
nous regrettons notre communauté c'est
qu'ensemble on se fait du shabbat et en
prononçant ce que l'on met fin au non
mes fans et sur instagram tous nos
réseaux qui sont pas ces petits mets ton
moi c'est vous parce que vous avez plus
voir passer moi qui promeut des comptes
d'autres filles que le mieux parce que
j'ai un compte y est et c'est
précisément pour une femme il ya les
crises fait de moi je pense qu'il ya pas
beaucoup d'abonnés fais comme je pense
que quand une fille me fais de la pub
moi je remets pas trop les gens parce
que c'est comme 14 abonnés là dessus
lorsque l'audience 16000 d'éclat jeu les
promos que la suisse ne soit pas du tout
mais c'est comme un échange comment veux
tu que je te dis tantôt mon meilleur
client qu'il ya du talent on a trois
fils et que c'est une de mes amis qui me
fait tâche à laquelle confiance et dark
phoenix s'ils voulaient d'agir si c'est
[Musique]
la meilleure pizza et d'enfants elle a
fait une pub pour moi moi j'ai fait une
pub pour elle puisque les ans la dédie à
sa bonne à nous deux qui seront de mon
meilleur client tu comprends mais c'est
pas grâce instagram du tout là parce
qu'elle était pasteur ans fumeuse pour
moi c'était avant tout d'un coup que
maxim knight abonnés à
trois quatre cinq six ans qu'ils veulent
ça des pensions portefeuille mais quand
je suis à des comptes gratuits aussi
fait qu'il y avait beaucoup que ils
s'abonnent à plein compte gratuit
picasso ce qui les intéresse c'est sa
vocation d'intérêt son combat j'ai mené
ce combat pour un mois du conflit parce
qu'il veut voir lettre non censurée ils
n'ont pas un million de martyrs il peut
marquer des costumes c'est super a cédé
en privé mais il aura accès fait que
pendant ce mois ci voilà ce mois-ci -
clap ils vont rester dans toutes les
gratuits en attendant n'ont fait que
c'est quand même c'est comme si tu es
des instagram
mais tout petit peu de débloquer des
trucs quand tu as envie tu m'intéresses
intéressant fake
mettons que les gens ils veulent pas
juste de suivre sur un iphone os qui te
suivent qu'est ce qu'ils font comme un
kiosque écouter de voix ou est ce qu'on
cherche c'est un de blagues et tout ce
qui touche autant les fans aussi à
l'arrêt une folle hausse sur owni fan
d'art in love libye d'abeilles ou non
mais c'est aussi un état grave que j'ai
pour ça et ce nom c'est la gauche qui
fait des vidéos sur youtube et sur
instagram
sinon j'ai un peu de caisse avec reste
elle est l'hôte de ré que c'est black
girls from aval je pensais peut-être des
même de démarrer un nouveau podcast de
la plongée en grosse [ __ ]
la grosse kifani grippe je sais pas
quelque chose qu'il s'agissait de 3,4 à
paris c'est sûr que c'est sûr que grosse
[ __ ] enfin parles sûrement public pour
sa 21e un peu mais je voulais tu seras
parler de sexe mais je parlais des côtés
négatifs là parce que c'est sympa que
les petites filles de 12 ans comme ouais
moi je le fais pour l'argent parce
qu'ils pensent que c'est de la môme
c'est pas toujours glamour que les côtés
mais déjà déjà beaucoup de gens qui
veulent que tu dépasses limite les
accents très insistants et tu fais pas
forcément autant d'argent que tu pense
pas qu'ils vont faire c'est vraiment
parce que si tu regardes les en
n'adoptant pas à faire de mes pièces par
mois parabole
c'est ça est très déçue longtemps pour
certains défauts notamment la qualité de
ce fait être que ça coûte plus cher
aussi
qu'est ce que tu penses pas ce que c'est
les gens qui vont acheter ton continuer
pour de la bande mais mon fils fait
environ 17 des abonnés puis à bursa
commentaires trop bonne chance exane
fois qu'ils n'ont pas aimé mais sauf
qu'ils reviendront plus mince il même si
avec des clients personnes photos des
lieux qui sont elles pas juste de petits
coins mi-temps des puces kader à la
faute et investissent dans les lieux qui
met pour des soutes et rouge
mais non même temps de travail il faut
toujours que tu investissent pour tâche
de nouveaux kits tout à fait pas usage
comme moi et que c'est plein de dépenses
qui fait que tu peux faire de l'argent
mais comme faut aussi se dépense
beaucoup dans son tracé comme tough de
débourser de l'épaule 15e temps payé ton
mais pour c'est pas parce que ce qui est
ce que
[Musique]
oui sauf que je pense le thé le
gouvernement je sais pas quel point tu
peux déclarer ses revenus le remède et
only fans du oui mais mettons
travailleurs du sexe je suis d'abord eu
dix travailleurs autonomes
ouais mais sinon moi je les attends très
très très partir mettant idées et des
impôts il faut c'est des factures non
c'est là que oui il n'a qu' il faut une
facture ne sait que m organisé qui fait
un cours de massothérapie ah ouais ouais
[Musique]
mettant rapidement le chèque en
indiquant que tom dey mais est ce que
est ce que maintenant tu voit d'un oeil
différent quelqu'un qui en est fan faire
sauf quelqu'un qui fait de la porn qui
me disent au point aux berceuses
quelqu'un qui fait du sex work qui
discute non non je sais qu'il ya des
gens qui veulent comparer puis se
trouvait au mieux la comment vais-je pas
dans la rue non ça reste du travail 10
et le résultat est le même
je veux dire non non ça même chose
d'assez comme c'est une dit jean pagé
podcasts émissions de radio tu parles
d'un micro et les jambes et au moins ça
n'est pas parce que le brise les radios
sont rediffusés à surmonter ses plus
nice et nice parce que j'ai pu écouter
quand tu veux mais tu commences à te
dire c'est comme servier c'est bon les
politiques musclées matin sur la route
non mais y en a entre autres les filles
ils se jugent entre elles parce qu'elles
trouvent une fois mieux que l'autre une
trouve que l'homme est virtuel tu voles
les gens l'ont trouvé en personne et
rabaisse puisque hommes mais les filles
ont put on peut te fais pas ce combat il
ya déjà tellement kitsch des patins
qu'il faudrait fermer nos gueules 5 et
moins ça a tendance plutôt que sur
d'autres
podcast blagueur pour mon aval c'est
tout ah oui je vais faire un numéro
d'humour avec mes camarades des
sorcières
mais ouais je n'étais pas des blagues en
fait il dit des choses et les gens henri
lacabanne sur cette émission c'est juste
que c'est une seule websérie le bénin
font maintenant c'est à votre carte
ok je pense que d'habitude moi j'ai déjà
été avec m dans live dans un resto je
pense à toi la souris tu encore jeune
j'ai été la pila maintenant ils vont à
cause de copie de maths où il enregistre
en version podcast que alors je vais
aller parler là très cool
en écho sonia jackson dessus par tous
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir évité